[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK SPATES: Good afternoon.
Thank you so much for coming
to the Smart Home talk.
The goal here is really to
give you guys a little bit
of understanding
and background on,
how do you connect a IoT
device to Google Assistant
so that you can allow that
device to be controlled
by the Google Assistant?
I'm Mark Spates.
I am the product lead for Smart
Home and the Google Assistant.
This is David Schairer,
kind of my partner in crime.
He's the engineering lead
for Smart Home and the Google
Assistant.
I think when you start to look
at some of the things that
are happening in this
space, it's really clear
that having a Assistant
control physical space
is going to be extremely
important moving forward.
So when we start to look at
Smart Home and the Google
Assistant, it was clear
that this was a feature
that we had to have when
Google Home launched last year.
The feature has become a pillar
of the Google Home experience,
and what users come
to expect when they're
interacting with the Assistant.
The other thing is,
the IoT market--
which you guys have
heard 1,000 times,
it's one of the biggest buzz
words of the last three years,
it's actually finally
going to happening.
And the Assistants are
part of that, right?
They're driving this
interaction with these devices.
So for us, we knew that there
was a unique opportunity
for the Google Assistant as
it relates to the Smart Home
space.
Just basic numbers,
these are the numbers
that you guys have seen
scene 1,000 times, right?
IoT is growing, and there's
a whole bunch of devices.
But I just want to look at 2017.
There's 8.4 billion
connected devices.
And out of that, you have
5.2 that are actually
consumer segment devices.
It's huge.
This means that having
that physical thing
in this space that's
connected to the cloud
is actually at a big
enough penetration
rate that having the Assistant
control it actually makes sense
to a user.
And those devices are
super diverse, right?
You have things from cars
and lights and fans and robot
vacuums.
I mean, I just got a
connected sous vide machine
delivered to my
desk so I can test
when I barbecue this weekend.
[LAUGHTER]
But that's how far we've come.
Everything will be connected.
And if it's connected, it should
be controlled at some level
by the Assistant.
The next thing that we
really start to look at
is, where does the Assistant
play in this user interaction?
And for us, it was always--
the Assistant will
be at the center
of these intelligent
interactions
with these IoT devices.
And we put the word intelligent
in there for a specific reason.
Today, a lot of the ways that we
control these things are simple
on and off switches.
They're actually
not intelligent.
You're simply sending
a on/off command,
and the thing goes
on and off, but it
doesn't take into consideration
context, device type, and all
these things that a user
would come to expect.
Which got us to this point in
our development, and we said,
it's about conversations,
not about commands.
And this is a core philosophy
that our team looks at.
And we make product decisions
and engineering decisions
based on this philosophy.
A user should be able to say
multiple things to a device,
right?
Not just turn this
device on, but if you
look at a light and
all the vast commands
you can give it just to simply
control it, it's amazing.
So you can change the color,
you can turn them on and off,
you can do things like
make the bedroom brighter.
Imagine yourself sitting
there with your spouse
or your roommate or
your best friend,
think about all
the ways that you
tell that person to turn the
light on or control the light.
It's extremely
different if you're
talking to your mom
versus your girlfriend
versus your boyfriend.
All these things we need to
be able to understand so we
can do what the user wants.
So to do this, we
had to get context.
We have to understand things
like, what is in the home?
What are the rooms in the home?
Who lives in that home?
This is the key reason our team
decided to create the Google
Home Graph.
The Google Home Graph stores
and provides the contextual data
about the devices in the
homes to the Google Assistant.
Now, this may
sound very similar.
You've heard these
things, right?
There's Knowledge Graph,
there's a graph for this,
there's a graph for that.
But actually, the home is
one of the last frontiers.
If you look at yourself
in your day to day,
if you walk out of
here, we pretty much
know that you got
a mobile phone,
this is your GPS locations,
and this is where you are.
Soon as you walk into
home, a lot of us
know that you walked in a
home, but we have no idea
what happens after that.
Are you in a living room?
Are you in the bedroom?
Are you watching TV?
Your phone may be in the
basement, you may be upstairs.
We have to have better
conceptual understanding
of the home to have a
really good experience.
So let's break down a Home
Graph really quickly, right?
We look at it as properties.
And there's three big
sets of properties,
and under there, there's
a lot of things that
build upon these properties.
So there's a structure.
That structure has to address,
it has managers, it has rooms,
it has labels, right?
Then you have rooms--
because rooms are very specific.
What I do in the bedroom and
what I do in the living room,
saying the exact same thing
can mean totally different
in the context, right?
So you have to understand where
you actually are in the home.
And there's devices.
Devices are extremely unique.
And we have to know, what
type of device is it?
What are the capabilities
of that device?
What are the attributes?
What's the current state?
And the reason is, there
are situations like this.
Let's go back to my example.
If you're sitting on the
couch, and you say, dim
the lights in the living
room a little bit, that's
a super complex
command or conversation
to even have with someone that's
sitting right next to you.
So using a Home Graph,
this is what we do.
We first say, are there any
lights in the living room?
Basic question.
OK, yeah, there's some
lights in the living room.
Next, are those
lights currently on?
OK, the current-- the lights
are on, that's awesome.
What are they set to?
Oh, these lights are on,
and they're set to 50%.
What does a little bit mean?
Well, in this case, a
little bit, may mean 3%.
It's a default thing
that we put in there.
We have-- we support things like
little bit, we support a lot.
Our interns put hella
in there because they're
from California.
But you have to know how to
increment based on those words,
right?
So we say, oh,
it's a little bit.
We're going to
increment by three.
We take that data,
we package it up,
and we pass it to
the Google Assistant.
And then Assistant
says, all right, got it.
I will change the
lights from 50% to 53%.
That's how the data
from Home Graph
is actually being
used in real time.
But it was awesome as
we were building this,
and we were saying
to ourselves, I
think we stumbled
upon what's going
to unlock this market
for everyone when
it comes to controlling
devices in the house.
So we have to get
this to developers.
How do we allow developers
to build interactions
that leverage Google
Assistant in the Home Graph?
So today I'm really excited
to introduce Smart Home apps.
Smart Home apps is a
experience that you can
build using Actions on Google.
I'm sure you guys have heard
tons about Actions on Google.
It is the greatest thing ever.
It is my favorite
platform Google's made.
But it's going to
be the way that we
go from this being a early
adopter platform to everyone
in this audience being
able to hook up something
to the Assistant,
leverage their Home Graph,
and control it in a
very conversational way.
But that's enough
about me talking.
I think for most
of you, you want
to see, how do you actually
build one of these things?
And with that, I'm going to turn
it over to David to give you
guys the developer experience.
DAVID SCHAIRER: Thanks, Mark.
[APPLAUSE]
So as Mark, said most
of you have probably
seen Actions on Google by now.
If you haven't, you
should definitely read up.
Actions on Google
is our new platform
to let you extend the
Assistant directly
to your applications, to your
services, and, in this case,
to your hardware.
So we've brought--
with this launch,
we're bringing
Smart Home devices
into the Actions
on Google platform.
We let you register your devices
directly to the Home Graph.
And rather than have the
Actions on Google model
where you talk to your
app, it changes the voice,
you interact
conversationally, you
can now have direct
actions that directly
communicate with your
devices, and everything else
in the home.
So if you have lights,
you register your lights
to the user's living room.
The user says, turn on my
lights in the living room,
it turns on your lights, it
turns on other vendors' lights.
It works seamlessly.
It's a descriptive grammar
that lets the user interact
naturally.
One of my coworkers
likes to say,
no one wants a light bulb
that asks too many questions.
So our system is designed for
those one shot single actions,
fire and forget,
everything just works.
How do we do this?
So you guys, you folks
that are building hardware,
building Smart Home devices--
light bulbs, thermostats, ovens,
sous vide machines, microwaves,
sprinklers, whatever--
you're building great hardware.
We want to make it really
easy for you to keep
building great hardware.
You provide a very lightweight
cloud infrastructure
on top of what
you're already doing.
You've already got cloud
control for these devices.
Add in OAuth,
which you all know,
some basic device sync,
execution and data integration
protocols.
All of these are stock JSON,
trivial stuff to implement.
And then we add on top
of that all of the stuff
that Google's good at--
the natural language
understanding,
the speech generation, the
personality, the Home Graph
that Mark talked about,
internationalization
and context, and error
management, and all
of these sort of complex
schemas of what does it
mean to be a washing machine?
And how do users interact
with washing machines?
We can apply learning,
we apply a lot
of our AI to these engines so
that they keep getting better.
And everything we improve,
you get the improvements
on as well.
We basically
integrate in two ways.
We have a flow for device setup,
we have a flow for execution.
This is the setup
flow, very simple.
I'm going to show you
all of this end to end.
Once you've registered,
you simply--
your app shows up in our
list of Smart Home apps,
a user clicks on it,
we send them off to you
for OAuth registration.
You would do whatever else
you want in that flow.
Come back to us, we send
a request for the devices,
you give us all the
devices that that user has,
any data you want.
It's a simple JSON protocol.
They have 17 lights,
they're called these things,
they're in these rooms, and they
have these traits associated
with them, what have you.
That's a full sync
each time, so you
don't need to do delta
state management,
we do all that for you.
We take that stuff, we
put it in the Home Graph.
Then at execution time,
we use our Assistant stack
to do all the heavy lifting.
We've gotten your state
from your devices,
we know what those
things are called.
Again, what their
capabilities are.
We feed that into our real
time speech recognition engine.
So if a user's named their
light something weird,
we understand it.
They have a chandelier in
their gazebo, that's just fine.
So speech recognition knows it,
natural language understanding
knows it, the Smart
Home engine knows it.
So all that stuff
lets us then build
the exact execution and query
semantics that we give you.
We feed those to you,
you do your task.
Again, simple JSON/HTTPS stuff.
Or maybe we generate the TTS--
the text response and speech
response to the
user, and it works.
We have built some
basic device types.
We're building a lot more device
types over the coming weeks
and months.
These device types are
composed of traits.
Traits are really where
functionality occurs.
So you have a trait of--
the simplest trait ever, on/off.
It means this
device has a switch.
Those traits then are made of
attribute states and commands.
On/off is pretty
simple, no attributes.
One state.
I bet you can guess what it is.
Pretty much one
command that just
is turning things on and off.
That trait then could be
composited into whatever
devices you want to make.
Right now, what we've
launched publicly,
those are lights and switches
and thermostats and the like.
You build a robot, you
can reuse that trait,
and make your robot
have an on/off trait.
Generally speaking,
all your robots
should have an on/off
trait, highly recommended.
Otherwise, problems occur.
So you'll be able to build--
as we roll out more
and more traits,
you can composite
your own device
types of whatever you want.
Maybe it's a clock radio that
has clock functionality, radio
functionality, and other stuff.
Maybe it's that robot that
combines standard traits
that we have plus custom
traits that you build.
We're releasing custom
traits soon where
you can build your own features
on top of this platform.
I'm going to walked
through the demo.
It's really simple.
We're going to do
this in six steps.
We're going to register
your project in the Actions
on Google platform.
We're going to set up OAuth.
We're going to implement
your Smart Home app.
I'm going to cheat
there a little bit.
We're going to use this
gactions command line
tool to test that package.
And once you do that, we're
going to go to the real app,
production level, no-- nothing
googly, nothing special,
production level Assistant
app in home control,
connect to your app,
set up your devices,
and then start talking to them.
So let's start the demo.
Great.
So this is the Actions
on Google console.
You may have played
with this already.
This is the new console
we launched yesterday.
I'm going to create a
project, give it some name.
Doesn't really matter for here.
I'm going to call
it Sheep Project,
see if it lets me do that.
This will take a few seconds.
What we're doing
here is creating
a project inside the
Actions on Google systems.
So it's assigning a project
ID, giving you all the tools
you need to build this.
Now, you may have seen
some of the API discussions
that we had earlier today.
We actually, today, are not
using API AI for the Smart Home
stuff because we've
written all the grammar.
You don't need to write any
grammar for these actions,
we provide it for you.
So we reuse the Assistant SDK--
or, Actions SDK.
We skip reading the docs
because we're developers.
And let's go and set
up the app information.
Now, a lot of the
stuff on this page,
honestly, we don't need for
home automation for Smart Home
projects.
But we're going to fill it
in anyway because currently
the application here wants it.
For example, the
Assistant voice,
because everything you do here
runs as a native Google app,
it's running native
understanding,
we can use the natural voice.
We don't need to change the
voice and make it feel jarring.
So we'll just say
home control demo.
Full description, demo.
We don't really care.
Category, let's pick
home control down here
at the bottom.
And what did I miss?
To control some stuff.
Obviously when you
do this for real,
since eventually
this will be going
to build in your
registry item, you'll
want some real text there.
Now it's asking for icons.
Same thing, I'm going to
load up some dummy ones.
And eventually these will be
used when you submit your app.
Away we go.
Testing instructions
we can skip.
My [INAUDIBLE] is
called Sheep Company.
Let's not think
about this too hard.
And feel free to spam me there.
Oops.
Privacy policy.
Just a dummy URL for now.
And it will think.
Great.
We've now created our project.
We have one more thing to do.
Number two on that list--
account linking.
So let's add some
Authorization code,
standard OAuth.
Let me go and grab my keys here.
Now, these are the standard
keys in the demo app
that we have put on GitHub.
Please do not use these OAuth
keys in your actual app.
I should not have
to tell you why.
Now, I'm just going
to set this up.
I'm using a stock [INAUDIBLE]
instance here right
off the shelf.
Signed it up onto the
node the other day.
So I'm not doing anything funky.
Testing instructions, demo.
OAuth should now be set up.
Now, over here I have--
this is our stock example app.
And all I'm going to
do is start this up.
You'll see this is sitting
behind an NGINX proxy.
You know, standard SSL stuff.
So not running now,
start this running.
Away we go.
Now, when I load this, I
should be able to go here--
and please don't hack into
my demo while I'm doing it.
Blam.
Now, this is a ver--
I know, I shouldn't
have said that.
You're doing it now.
When the lights start going on
crazy, I know it's one of you.
This is our example app.
We've shipped this app for
testing out the application.
These are virtual lights.
We actually used this
in our own development
because I can't get 100
light bulbs at my desk.
People complain.
So when we need to
do scale testing,
we tend to do it
with virtual devices.
So I can turn those on
and off, set these up
for cloud registration.
Now, I now have an app running.
My next step, I'm
going to hop over here,
and I am going to
find the action.
We have this gactions
command here, which simply--
oops.
This takes the action--
actually, before we do that, let
me show you the action package.
So you may have
seen action packages
and other demos that have lots
and lots of stuff on them.
Ours is really simple.
That's all there is.
You put the URL to
use for execution
in there, execution in sync,
everything else is stock.
And then I can run this.
I can go and grab my
project ID, which happens
to be easily right here.
And if I didn't forget
something because I'm on stage,
I can do that.
And of course it
will ask me to update
while I'm on stage because
apps know when you're on stage.
Skip that.
Pushing the app.
Now it should be live.
I'm going to go over
here to the phone.
Oops.
Here on the phone,
restart the Assistant.
Go into Settings, Home
Control, I have no devices.
Plus.
There is my app.
So my app that I just
created and I just ran
is now available just like
all of our production partners
here.
And I click on
that app, and I now
have to type this, which
you'll probably see.
Whoops.
Yeah, yeah, yeah,
please hack in.
I should put it a paste buffer.
All right, if I
did that right, I
got OAuth, linking my devices.
And then these four
lights that I put up here
are now available on the phone.
I'm going to skip rooms
because I don't really
care about that right now.
And I can say--
going to go back
to the Assistant.
Turn on all my lights.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: Sure,
turning four lights on.
DAVID SCHAIRER: All right,
two of those decided
to get knocked off the cloud.
If they weren't on the cloud--
turn on all my lights.
And there go the other ones.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT:
Turning four lights.
[APPLAUSE]
DAVID SCHAIRER: Make
my lights, green.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: Sure,
changing four lights to green.
DAVID SCHAIRER: So
pretty simple stuff.
We have lots of other
device types-- thermostats,
more complex things.
This is the base case.
And you saw, yes, I did cheat.
We have a little Node.js
instance over here.
But that's all it takes.
So with that, I will
turn it back to Mark.
MARK SPATES: Awesome.
Great demo, David.
[APPLAUSE]
That was awesome.
So you go and crush it
like David just did.
You build your stuff in 36
hours, and you're ready to go.
But there's still a
couple more things
you have to do to launch it.
First, send me a device,
because I have to test it.
But then, once you send
the device over to Google
and you deploy your
action, we will then
do a certification process.
And the certification
process is really simple.
We do have a few testers go
through, test basic things--
latency, make sure that
the policies and privacy
things are correct.
And then once that's
all done, we say,
all right, this
looks really good,
and this is ready to go to
production after we certify it.
And then we launch
it into production.
So it's a really simple process.
We are making sure that
the experience that the end
user is getting is really good.
So that's where the
certification process comes in.
Just to make sure things
like the right grammars work,
and the expectations
around latency are set.
We have a bunch of partners
who have been working with us.
They've helped us
build this process.
And we are super
excited because they've
helped us learn a lot about
what we can do better.
But more importantly,
I think, the rapid pace
in which we've been adding
Smart Home integrations has
been amazing.
We started with
three integrations.
In the keynote, you heard
our team say we have 70 now.
And we did most of those
in the last six weeks
using this process.
So we extremely excited to
open this up to everyone
so we can go even faster.
So you might say
like, what's next?
The first thing is,
everyone leave here,
don't go to the concert,
go build a Smart Home app.
Then go to the concert, right?
But there's other things that
you may want to check out.
There are going to be more
device support, more features
and all that coming the
next couple of months,
as David said.
Also, all these
integrations are on display
in some of the Sandboxes.
So if you go to the
Assistant Sandbox,
if you go to IoT's Sandbox,
you see a lot of these things
already on display.
And it's running in
production, which is awesome.
And the last one is that
we work really closely
with the Assistant SDK team.
So if you're thinking
about, how do I actually
embed the Assistant
into my device,
you should check out
the Assistant SDK.
[MUSIC PLAYING]